everybody seems to think that Obama is
in his heart an atheist and in his heart
is skeptic the church he belonged to in
Chicago is a whack-job Church it's about
equal to Palin's church granted he
hasn't been as religious as do we know
do we know off the top of our heads the
most religious president in history in
terms of references referencing to God
references to God and in terms of
appearing in churches who the most
religious president history was it's an
interesting answer and I got this
information from NPR so it's probably
not slanted in the way you'd think the
most religious president in history in
terms of appearances and churches and
mentions of the Bible was Clinton Bill
Clinton is the most religious president
we've had he beats George Bush hands
down and he beats Carter who you know
was a born-again Christian he beats him
hands down so Obama does that too I mean
to the 9/11 thing maybe appropriately he
read from the Bible but you have two
choices with Obama you either believe
that he is a man of Christ who prays for
decisions in the White House which he
said he was or you think he's a liar and
I'm surprised by the number of atheists
free thinkers that support Obama and
their argument is essentially he's lying
about being religious because you have
to do that to be elected I'm not happy
with either one of those I mean Obama is
wicked smart he's a wicked good talker
there is no doubt in my mind that his
heart is in the right place
unfortunately I think that about almost
every president we've had but I think he
wants to do good I don't think there's
any malicious quality to him at all but
I think it's some sense he's a believer
or he's a liar so 1 to 10 I rate them
pretty high on the skepticism maybe a 6
or a 7 but I rate him that way because
somewhere by heart I think he might be
lying about being religious
and that's horrible it's a horrible
reason to like somebody I like him cuz
he may be a liar
horrible Michele Bachmann's blasphemy is
greater than anything I've ever
accomplished I have tried with friends
to say the most blasphemous sentence I
can possibly say and it does not come
close to the blasphemy of Michele
Bachmann saying that earthquakes and
hurricanes were the way God was trying
to get the attention of politicians I
cannot imagine a serious religious
person reading that quote or hearing
that quote and saying yeah right on it
is solipsistic it is opportunistic it is
cynical it is deep and it is wrong and
it is an insult to religious people
everywhere for an atheist it's it's a
burlesque it's a little bit of a joke
you can dismiss her but I can't see it
as an atheist I see it from through my
father's eyes you know my father was a
Christian his whole life and if he had
heard Michele Bachmann say that he would
have looked away from the TV the idea
that you would lightly state that people
were suffering and dying in order to to
prove that God was on the side of one
politician is sickening the only reason
that Bachmann and Rick Perry are able to
say this stuff is because of a magic
word and this magic word is Christian
and if you look back in history the word
Christian doesn't really appear in the
way we use it today until the
anti-abortion debate in the 60s when you
had 1890 into the 19th century
your top three highest-paid speakers the
highest paid speakers were atheist
speaking about atheism
robert ingersoll number one mark 20
number two Huxley number three Ingersoll
was the the great infidel the great
skeptic the Atheist Mark Twain of course
and these are people speaking on he was
not reading from it was not reading from
Oxfam he was reading from letters from
earth he was reading atheist stuff and
Huxley of course Darwin's a pit ball I
guess bulldog at that time I think of it
as pit bull there was a real sense of
atheism being an important point they
were invited to the White House and the
reason was that Catholics were terrified
of Baptists who were terrified of
Pentecostals or a terrified of
Lutheran's who were terrified of
evangelicals the whole list
there wasn't a feeling of Christian the
founding fathers were very afraid of
Baptists taking over from the
Pentecostals everybody was afraid of the
Catholics so you had this divided thing
if we still had that if we still were
dividing people by sects like we should
be sects like we should be one of the
largest groups in this country would be
atheists by the USA Today poll I think
it was 22 percent 20 percent even the
lowest polls put it at eight okay the
next highest would be Catholics and
they'd be knocking around 20 you know
then you've got all your divided up
categories and then abortion happens a
legalized abortion and some very smart
people very forward-thinking people
decided we can never fight abortion if
it's the Catholics fighting the
Protestants who find the Baptist's
fighting the Pentecostals finding it we
have to get them under one tent and
there's a great book on this called the
history of free thought because these
are not my ideas they pull this tent
together and they kind of create the
word Christian and then Carter with
born-again Christian really helps with
the word Christian so what they've
really done is they've taken very
different philosophies I mean
Catholicism and product.the
Protestantism
very different philosophies very
different you know and they pulled it
together to make this term Christian
which are people that don't agree at all
and they say I'm doing a Christian
message
so Michelle Bachmann and Rick Perry just
40 years ago really recently would have
been terrified to speak about their God
in their church because the second they
said they were Baptist the second they
said they were Pentecostal the second
they said they were Lutheran all the
other people fall away but now they've
got this magic word Christian and I am
helping make it worse because by using
the word atheist I am separating that
even more from Christian I'm doing a
broader umbrella and I'm making theist
atheist and if you do theist atheist the
theists win completely you know what I
should be doing if I were a political
thinker if I were someone that was
interested in movements which I'm not
I'm against them if I wasn't for
individual thinking I would be one of
those people who was saying using a term
like free thinker or open-minded and I
would be gathering this umbrella that
included people who self-identify as
agnostic atheist against organized
religion I would get the Wiccans in
there I don't get as many people as
possible and I could probably pump that
up to 25% and then I would be also
saying well you know the Muslims are
very different from the Jews who are
very different from the Catholics who
are very different from all of that but
what's going to happen and because I'm
not interested in tactical play or
rather in telling the truth we are going
to get theist atheist but you can't
imagine we can't imagine in 1965 a
Baptist talking Baptist politician
talking about religion and where they
go to church if they have to use the
word Baptist it's using the word
Christian that allows this craziness to
happen it's also because I am an
optimist to the point of being incorrect
to the point of not being realistic
that's what flushes over me it's what I
feel in my heart is optimism I tend to
go with something Christopher Hitchens
said and I remember where he said it
could have even been in personal
conversation I don't know but Hitchens
said that what we're seeing with this
incredible crazy religious stuff is the
death throes I mean since 9/11 free
thinking atheism is growing so quickly
because of the internet and people who
we're seeing it first with those who are
called and I realized this is a racist
term but it's the easiest one to use so
please forgive me
gypsies we're seeing with the Amish
we're seeing it with the acidic all the
groups that try to stay as a subset of
America and keep their own traditions
are going away and Elvis chipped away at
them and mauls chipped away at them but
the Internet's going to take them down
it's just too hard to keep your children
cloistered they're going to hear Katy
Perry there's just no way to stop it
they're gonna see video like this you
know once you've gotten on the Internet
to see Katy Perry it's not hard to fall
over to the big thing it's the same
keyboard it's the same screen it's the
same everything and those that
information gets out there and I think
that everybody knows that and everybody
feels that so those who are religious
you're seeing a desperate terrified
clawing and that's the only way you can
explain Michelle Bachman and Rick Perry
is the combination of desperation
coupled with the magic protective word
of Christian the problem is a movement
of individuals is not going to have the
muscle of a cohesive movement
people who believe they're right and I'm
not willing to lie to fight them
I want individuals who disagree on
everything and I want us to learn to
band together for freedom band together
in order to be different and that's a
much harder thing to sell but it's all
that matters so we have to do it
Mitt Romney is wearing crazy underwear
he's wearing magic underwear he is I
mean under his pants he is wearing magic
underwear magic underwear and he
believes that a convicted conman got
golden tablets and no one else could see
and sat with an angel to find out that
the original Jews of the Bible were
living in North America crazy crazy
crazy crazy crazy but just more modern
not more crazy than other religions not
more crazy than Islam you know with your
with not more crazy than virgin births
and resurrections not more crazy than
any of that stuff it fascinates me that
you can have the Bible Belt and you can
have a court trial and we've seen this
I'm gonna use it hypothetically but
you'll know the specifics I'm talking
about I just don't want to talk about
that kind of pain directly it's too
unpleasant for me but hypothetically if
a Bible Belt where you can have a
born-again Christian judge born-again
Christian judge I believe the the Bible
is the literal word of God there were
talking snakes they were talking snakes
and virgin births burning bushes and
Abraham being willing to kill his son
for God he believes that the jury is
made up of 12 people who let's say 10 of
them believe that and 2 of them believe
that but a little less your
prosecuting attorney believes that the
people that are sitting in the courtroom
believe that these are all people that
know each other in church and the person
on the witness stand says that she
killed her three children in cold blood
because God told her to and every single
person in the courtroom decides whether
she is guilty or not guilty by reason of
insanity those are the two choices they
weigh and nobody not the defense
attorney not the judge not the jury
people not the people in the gallery not
one person stands up and goes maybe God
told her to it's it's less weird than
the talking snake maybe God told her to
and in this country which they say over
and over again is founded on Christian
values and I'll give them that founded
on Christian values okay it is fine this
country found that on Christian values
has guilty not guilty not guilty by
reason of insanity end of list there is
nothing that says not guilty
because God told me to and why why isn't
that there why isn't this country
allowing in the court system someone to
go on the witness stand and go snake
walk up to me snake open his mouth snake
said going to McDonald's pull out an 8k
15 kill 10 people walk back out snake
told me that it's that snake there he's
not talking anymore I throw myself on
the mercy of the court
aren't you all good Christians don't you
believe in the miracles of the Bible
you're seeing one now and that's that's
the part that amazes me is that kind of
stuff so Mitt Romney comes along
and at some level doesn't he know what
he believes is crazy
at some level isn't he going there
weren't Jews in North America you know
that's not where the Garden of Eden was
doesn't that go through his mind and
that's the part of that whole thing that
kills me if Mitt Romney really believes
what he says he believes he is bug nutty
batshit crazy and he's not bug nutty
batshit crazy he is the same as Obama if
Obama believes what he was being taught
in that church in Chicago okay
he is batshit crazy and Obama is
demonstrative ly not batshit crazy so we
have this weird deal we make with all
the politicians where we say you can say
you believe bug nutty batshit crazy shit
and we'll shrug it off because you're
clearly not bug nutty batshit crazy
and all I want out of our politicians is
for them to just say you know a lot of
the religious stuff I'm talking about is
bug nutty batshit crazy but I'm not
because I don't think any of these men
and women are crazy and I'll even give
you Michele Bachmann I'll even give you
Rick Perry I'll even give you Sarah
Palin I don't have that cynical MSNBC
point of view that they are bug nutty
batshit crazy I think they are good
people
who somehow think that their morality
and their love for humanity and their
love for their families are tied up in
this weird tradition and when they think
that the Bible is the Word of God I
think they mean something else I
sometimes think that many other people
are speaking in a code that I've not
been given the key to when someone says
to me I believe in the Bible literally
well I personally Penn Jillette read
about a chapter of the Bible
day I just read through it over and over
again so when someone says they believe
in the Word of God literally I go back
and think about Genesis where people are
living to be 900 years old and I say
bullshit and I think about Noah and the
flood killing everybody God that loves
us kills everybody and he wants to get
two of every species and seven of the
ones that are clean onto a boat that
floats for that amount of time and I
just go really because you don't act
that way you're able to go to Home Depot
you're able to play pay with a credit
card you're able to go to Starbucks you
know how to use the computer really do
you really mean that
what do you mean literally do you really
mean you're gonna stone someone to death
who because they work in the Sabbath are
you're really gonna do that really
honestly you're gonna take a rock in
your hand and throw it in the
motherfuckers head because he worked on
a Sunday to support his family are you
really gonna do that if you mix cotton
and linen and your clothing are you
really gonna go to hell what do you mean
when you say that and no one's ever
answered me there's a cold going on that
I need the rosetta stone I need someone
to sit me down into a pen but Obama says
he went to that church and they talked
about all this stuff being literal what
he really meant was fill in the blank
tell me what does he really mean these
people are good honest smart not batshit
crazy people so why the fuck are they
saying batshit crazy stuff to me
you